yeah yeah the only thing I didn't want
you do the only thing that irritated me
about you when we started here we go
yeah I just didn't like that you relied
on hair for laughs that always got under
my skin you know I told you I told you
that many many times when he first
started it was the it was real super
high he'd go and I would go Oh Bobby you
know you're good enough without you know
to me yeah but you sort of you see you
don't do that anymore that's Ned that's
how Ned got me off of it it's so funny
that's the same advice that he gives all
the younger comics is like you cannot
rely on anything about your physical
appearance and that's what I used to do
oh yeah because everything has been what
happens everything I say is from my own
experience you know that's all you you
know what else I'm so glad I'd never
I've always been a slow starter you know
that I always start off what low - I'm a
sell order no no sir
opposite of that why you come right out
of the chute no you grab the mic and
then everybody just goes crazy
no no but anyway I've always been a
little bit slower and then I get I get
my wheels going in whatever but you know
what I always wanted I always wanted ice
envy the comics who did have something
that they'd go onstage and they would
not so much like looks or stuff you know
those comics you have that one line
they'll walk up and they open with a
line dude and it just crushes the room
and then everybody loves them but I'm so
glad I didn't because some of those
comics are still opening with that line
20 [ __ ] years so it becomes this
crutch you know I sort of like that's
why you tell young guys don't get too
much into the physic I know what asian
guy right and I'm gonna say his name but
he relies so heavily on the Asian accent
maybe he can't he can't not do a set
without it and then even when he
auditions for things then it's not even
in the description of the character
he'll just make a choice and do an Asian
accent because he knows that that's a
strength right but it's a crutch
yeah yeah now right I used to have that
I did the hair thing I used to wear a
cowboy hats and
overalls and later I just saw that I
never saw this I should bring that up
right now is it it's your headshot with
a cowboy hat you wore that though those
I never saw yeah I used to work hard I
had and I used to go hee-haw and the
whole thing I don't know why this was a
San Diego ya know I would can I go grab
it
no no don't grab it I believe you I
believe you I know I remember what photo
it is yeah we want to see it I'll go get
it done babe now remember us dressing up
in cowboy clothes clothing on the rice
and beans tour remember that right and
that was that you were the funniest that
was the funniest look I think I've ever
seen anybody in my entire life was you
dressed up as full-on cowboy if you
don't know what rice and beans is when
Johnny got on the mat you see I pitched
a up thing where Johnny and I go across
the country the Midwest the Midwest
south and trying to find American stuff
I think still that it would be a great
you know tell you dude it was good but
he was a problem for me what he's gay
and everybody will notice this I hadn't
even done an episode of mad yet okay we
shot this the summer before I started
shooting the sketches yeah so I didn't
know this guy is seven seasons in at
this point eight seasons what John is
saying is if you watch them now because
you can see him on a youtube right he
had just gotten the show so so he was in
his head he was so green and like
editing everything in his head like what
deal what not to do Italy right so here
we go what that doesn't even look like
you really handsome you look really
different
dude I that was cute that's a good look
you look like Matt Gummer eek lift there
like he was in like I think the
Magnificent Seven
yeah yeah look at this thing then dude
let me see that yeah I mean I really
wasn't you know what I was expecting to
see him with it with a hat like barely
sitting on because his hair is so big
and he's making that yeah this is
actually I used to walk into lumber
yards because that's what that's the
look I would have when I used to I used
to work for a construction company and
my job was to
go and pick up materials but I would
dress like that that's how I used to
dress so I was used to walk into like
yump lumber yards and have everyone as
soon as I they see me they just burst
into laughter oh so you they yep see it
started her and started early this is
before stand-up that's before stand-up
right so I used to come in with a cowboy
hat but real I put a little toothpick in
my mouth right a little what
[Music]